[Music]
[Music]
hi and welcome to wisdom for life where
we sit through the philosophy to find
practical advice that you can use in
your everyday life I'm Dan and I'm
joined by my co-host dr. Greg Sadler
today we're talking about big topic work
meaning and the future and what we mean
by this is the fact that work is
becoming transformed before our eyes
into something quite different than it
was a decade ago let alone you know our
childhood so we're facing a world in
which there might not actually be enough
work for human beings there definitely
will be for the robots and AI and other
things that we're going to talk about so
what will the world look like and how
can we adjust ourselves to this or plan
for it what's the prudent thing to do
and this is a really messy subject
because you know we're speculating into
the future prognosticating yeah yeah but
like we do have some road guides and we
have a number of different paths that we
might go down kind of depending on the
situations that we're going to find
ourselves in and as we go through them
we can say like is this a good path or
is it's not a good path at least you
know from a subjective point of view or
objective point of view for depending on
what our criteria is for defining what
is a good life for us and see if we at
least know the paths we can potentially
work to try as you bring us down to a
path that we are all happy with or at
least most of us are I don't think
you're gonna get everybody on one sheet
especially if there's people who like
really like being on top and you know
being in control of everything it's
gonna be a hard sell to say well we
should have a Star Trek sort of future
unless they're the Admiral in charge of
Starfleet right right
so it's interesting that Starfleet has
this you know for I guess you know the
people on earth and for most of the
people it's like it's boring like
you know relatively like there's
everyone that like has real ambition
goes to like star flee because that's
where you get to do wild and crazy
things you get to work on the edge on
and but like you know when you go bashes
like oh yeah like I run a restaurant and
like the people come because I have
really good food but not because I'm
like making money because it's there's
no future
yeah space capital space communism fully
automated space communism yeah and you
know so before we jump in we should talk
a little bit about something we brought
up and I forget which episode it was
we're talking about Star Trek and a
post-scarcity future and this issue of
excitement and and meaning and there's
another similar sci-fi speculative
fiction I mean it is a really hard
sci-fi series where this is the case as
well and that's iron banks culture
series right
so how do we have this this same dynamic
where you got a really soft gooey inside
and then on the outside shell you've got
a hard you know we could say honor and
integrity driven also a pretty
competitive set of people who are
protecting it and and and they kind of
support each other right all the
economic stuff is coming from this
massive dynamo of human beings who are
they you know the technology is there so
they can replicate anything but they
also really love what they they do even
though it's not exciting most of the
time you know some of them are musicians
and some of them are like you said
restaurant owners and presumably some of
them are you know game masters yeah
exactly but you can't you can't have it
because you've got all these other races
right and start in Star Trek it's the
Klingons until they become effectively
domesticated and part of the Federation
right and then you got the Romulans the
next baddies and then the Cardassians
and a few things like the board who will
never truly be assimilated until I don't
know maybe maybe they are and the new
Picard thing right so you other post
pork oh that's right yeah yeah
there they've assumed semi-human status
again right alright or not just human
because they could be all sorts of races
but you've got this you've got this
dynamic where youyou have to have the
everything is fair and everything works
and then you've got the interface with
the rest of the hard mean universe which
is Starfleet or what was it in what was
the name of it special circumstances
that's really the culture spheres and
it's interesting because they have two
different kind of dynamics whereas like
for the vast majority of Star Trek the
Starfleet is really high-minded they're
like oh you know I don't want to
interfere with other civilizations
especially early on and cultures like no
we don't care we're gonna like we have
our softener and we have a really high
minded ideals within their but special
circumstances like yeah you know there's
a developing civilization over here
they're like medieval tech level yeah
we're gonna like put an age agents to
almost a month and to change their
morality to be something that is more in
line with them so that they're easily to
easier to assimilate into their
civilization later on yeah yeah there's
there's a definite difference there
although I mean Starfleet has its moral
dilemmas that arise right right I mean
the prime directive is brought up so
many times because they're always
tempted to break it circumstances like
yeah we don't even have that we just
like it it's very utilitarian ends
justify the means how can we get this
done
yeah in order to make sure that the
internal can continue doing the things
that it does so back to our planet back
to our presence back to you know we've
got some you know good recommendations
for if you haven't read ion banks
culture series you should probably give
it a shot if you like that sort of thing
but what we're facing here today is you
know it's definitely not a everything is
going swimmingly sort of situation of a
post-scarcity future instead you know
we're in some tough times and people are
encountering great psychological
stresses and
Cole teased and facing up to the fact
that work is changing for us in very
unpredictable and in in the way that it
is predictable seemingly dismal ways so
we should talk about some of the big
factors do you want to you know focus on
some of the ones that you think are the
most important in this situation what
things is automation both in robotics
and AI on like we produce more than we
did in the 80s with like a third of the
workforce or maybe a quarter of the
workforce you know the output is still
up there we're still you know a
manufacturing powerhouse not as much as
some other countries but it's just like
the jobs that used to be there are gone
yeah and and then AI is you know there's
this term that you know software is
eating everything and now what does it
mean that's that's actually a really
good slogan yeah you know you know just
with it with software we can automate a
whole bunch of things like there's there
are robotics but that all runs in
software you look at like accounting
lots of accounting is being eaten eaten
by software packages that do what
accountants used to do oh there he is a
glut of lawyers that have no ability to
actually practice law because people
like I want to say it Siemens not
Siemens on there's a number of companies
that do automated document review and so
this used to be a really labor-intensive
thing for lawyers you look through case
law and you look through any relevant
documents when he went through discovery
and it was like you like just reading
and reading and reading and trying to
find anything that you could use to
support your case and now they have AI
that like scans all the documents and
then figures out what is actually
relevant then the presents that to you
like a thousandth of the subset of what
you would have had to do in the future
and so this was actually where most
lawyers got their foot into many law
firms as these paralegals so that's
that's a really let's pause on that
first
that's a really interesting issue that
you put your finger on in talking about
getting not just their foot the door but
getting a kind of training so something
similar happened in the humanities we
talked about the digital humanities and
part of that has been you know the
putting all of these texts into
searchable digital formats right so what
we do nowadays if you're studying say
Cicero quite often I mean I I still kind
of old school where I'll go and like
look through the book and and I think I
there's a reference here to something I
just don't remember where it is but even
I will oftentimes do like you know word
searches either in the English
translation or the Latin and find
exactly what I'm looking for now if you
do that you're missing out on the
development of a set of skills you know
and I'll give you another prime example
of this so students these days in have a
library that actually has open stacks
and volumes that they can go and look in
they don't they go to the computer and
they go to JSTOR for articles and they
you know look up you know if they need a
book they look up where it is and then
they might go to the shelf and get it
down from that place or they might just
request a librarian to go get it for
them and then they pick it up at the
front desk and what you miss out on is
the dithering around in the stacks
looking at at books and saying oh that
that one looks kind of interesting too I
should check that out or finding things
that you didn't realize were there like
when I did my research for the the one
you know big academic book that I've
published up until this point I did it
at the Notre Dame Hesburgh library and I
would literally go to a set of volumes
that contain the journals from like say
1929 to 1941 and just like page through
them and now this might might strike a
lot of people while that that was a
waste of time holy crap I can't believe
that you know you did all that but you
find all these other things along the
way and you also in some sense learn
your craft so if lawyers are not doing
this document review they're probably
losing something important along
the way all right okay and I think we
could say this for a lot of other fields
as well you know think about tool and
die operators so most of that became you
know pretty automated in in the 90s you
know where there'd be some some fairly
primitive from our perspective software
running things but you'd still have to
know what you're doing like you said you
don't really need that many people doing
this sort of thing or if you're doing
like plastics you know if you're if
you're doing a molding of things you
know you put the model into the computer
and then you know put the right kind of
plastic in and it takes care of it for
you you don't you don't have this
getting engaged in the material itself
or think about car mechanics right I
mean they still do some basic things but
a lot of times they like hook the car up
to the Diagnostics and they're like is
in like the Little Britain episode you
know computer says no and then you know
what's what's the remedy
yeah swap out these chips for these
chips so there's there's a lot of fields
where the humans are in some respect
becoming redundant yeah reminds me of
listening to Car Talk back in the day
yeah like he's like what what's this the
the noise that you hear and like what
corner of the car do you think it's
coming from and what's your make and
model and they make you like deduce that
just from like these this sounds and
feels in the description of how it rode
whereas you know that that is very
tactile and very close learning yeah is
just not there for I guess a lot and and
to go back to your point on on academic
read learning that's exactly like I've
I've spent very little time just kind of
dithering in the stacks yeah and and I
use judicial use of find in text yeah
and I'm not a Luddite I love the fact
that I can get literally tens of
thousands of articles at my fingertip
just with a few keystrokes but there is
something that's that's being missed
and I think academics academics are
their own economic problems but I think
that they don't really
to be worried at this point about being
replaced by computers but so many other
fields that is the case right and it's
not just blue color it is also white
color there's a lot of you know what
specifically lawyers is one that's
already being eaten and can you come up
with one that people might have more
sympathy with on engineers computer
science a lot of these STEM fields that
you know usually would be considered oh
those are really good you know
respectable white-collar jobs yeah on
the way or a lot a lot of people right
yeah and uh these are things that like
at least the lower levels will be more
automated and there's already a certain
neural network ii do certain programming
and it's like oh oh no what are we doing
here I was gonna say does that making
you sweat a bit or not no why not
because I like to mess around with
making neural networks so that's one of
the answers that people always put
forward you know well you know there's
the computers are gonna take everything
over but it's okay we're not gonna lose
jobs because we're still gonna need
human beings to like you know decide
what the computers are gonna do and
program program them and you know when
you hear that you think okay salt they
will need some people to do that what
about all the other people are we gonna
create kind of silly jobs for them like
George Jetson where he goes in and his
whole job is just to push a single
button you know is that really a job is
that is that just kind of like keeping
him cooped up so he doesn't go nuts
because he he's got too much time on his
hands right what's the point
just make busy work and we're already in
a point where make busy work is kind of
the norm for a large percentage of our
population you know that's an
interesting observation and that that's
that's one that could have been made a
long time ago I think you're aware of
the book the Peter Principle right
vaguely okay so it was it was written I
believe in the sixty
it might have been even earlier in the
50s and it was about hierarchical
organizations because back then a lot of
a lot of business and a lot of you know
other things educational military were
all these these fairly well-defined
hierarchical organizations and you'd
move up through seniority or you know
doing a good job or something like that
and you know they're kind of command and
control is what we would call them and
Peter said that most people within
organizations are not actually doing any
productive work and it's because they've
here's the key Peter Principle
people will rise to their level of
incompetency so if you're good at the
level one they'll they'll promote you
and then you might be good at level two
and if you are good at level two they'll
promote you again but if you're not any
good at it you're gonna stay at level
two they're not gonna kick you back down
to level one unless you're a real
screw-up because they don't want to
admit that they made a mistake in
putting you in promoting it and put it
here at a higher place right so you get
there and then you don't do any really
productive work because you're
incompetent at what you're doing so you
become a manager right you're at a
restaurant you wash dishes and then
maybe you become you know you start
doing prep and stuff like that and
everything's going great and then they
make you assistant manager and you're
terrible at it but they're not going to
get rid of you as assistant manager and
you don't get any work done and you get
in the way of the other people who do so
his estimate was only twenty percent of
the people at any given organization are
actually doing real work that was a long
time yeah yeah and it would make sense
that we wouldn't find those people that
are doing a job really really well and
maybe just pay them more for that work
because if they are the best at that
then yeah and you should do that
and you go fine so I feel like part of
it is that like we we have these
hierarchies and we have this idea that
if you're higher and higher you also
must have a corresponding increase in
your pay and and maybe exponential right
right and and maybe odd it like if you
were system manager you're not actually
making more than your workers
ah maybe there are certain workers that
are just really good at their jobs and
those are much more valuable to you and
you might be better for you to just have
them keep on doing that just pay them a
little bit more yeah Peters suggestion
was much more individualistic which is
if you should make sure that you don't
rise to your level of incompetence so
you find a spot that you like and then
you start developing some quirks that he
called creative incompetence start
showing up late or you know say weird
stuff in meetings or something like that
just to make sure that you're not going
to get promoted to the next level I
don't know if that would work today that
might get you fired instead it's right
so so let's come back to today's stuff
so yeah you know one of the things
that's really radically changed the the
landscape of work is the several decades
of deregulation and the fact that
companies keep getting you know
consolidated and bought up so you know
when you have a company that is
innovative and doing a good job one of
the big tech companies will come along
and gobble them up or they'll be run we
have hospitals that are essentially
being run by venture capitalist firms
and and you know this this leads to a
lot of of problems because the
organization is not being run by people
who actually want that organization to
be doing its main mission it becomes
about making more and more money and
being more and more productive and one
of the ways to do that is to start
minimizing the number of humans involved
so reducing the the number of viable
work spots you could say alright and and
this is one of the things that's been
coming up as well who actually derives
the the benefits from robotics it's the
people who own the robots so it's it's
not like robotics would automatically or
AI or logistics or all these other
wonderful things would automatically
turn into a better future for all of us
it turns into a better future for
whoever owns and directs so this is a
good transition point I think maybe to
thinking about
what work means for us because if people
are being put out of work what are they
losing I mean we often talk like a job
is on the one hand or right although we
you know right to work actually means
they can fight again whenever they want
to or you know at will employment it
rather it means that right to work means
you can't unionize in easy ways but but
then you know a lot of people really do
want to work they may not want to work
the job that they have or they do want
to work the job that they have but not
under the conditions that they they have
it what does it mean when people are put
out of their jobs our jobs something
like a basic good that that everybody
should have access to well this is kind
of like it kind of depends on which
culture you're in like yeah in States
has a very long history from our Puritan
roots and we have this Puritan work
ethic this you know I guess our German
immigrants also kind of had this a
little bit on but they like to be have a
job and be employed is to be good and
let that feels like it's it's very
pervasive still in this day and age and
if we are looking at a on a future in
which there are fewer and fewer jobs
then there are fewer fewer people who
are like good you can like see this all
the time one like there's that the meme
of like someone yelling at the homeless
person get a job yeah because they're
not you know a good person you're not
like participating in society yeah and
the idea was also if you didn't get a
job you wouldn't be this homeless person
stinking occupying space being idle you
know the job would be sort of like a
magical transformation thing that in a
month or so you know two paychecks would
suddenly turn you into a productive
citizen and member of the community
right and that's - that might have been
the case in in earlier times I mean I
remember when I was a college student if
I didn't like a job I could leave it and
I wouldn't find a great job after that
but guaranteed by the end of the week
I'd have some other crappy you know
anywhere from minimum wage to twice
minimum wage job that would would pay
for the stuff that I wanted to pay for
you know that just is not the case today
you know I mean you have to apply quite
often online for positions and and it's
a lot harder to get into jobs and hold
on to them so you know one year oh go
ahead another toilet thing is that like
our health insurance is also tied to a
lot that also gets you kind of stuck
with a job if you don't like it you're
kind of you know Sol yeah and this is
actually on a funny thing like my house
in my house and it's a triplex
and if I don't want to work I can rent
it out and and I can subsist on the rent
it's not a great subsistence but at
least it allows me that opportunity that
I will know that I will not starve if I
don't have a job and and so it's my fu
house and a you know just the ability to
say I don't need this job to any
employer which is kind of this rarefied
position that not a lot of people
actually have yeah and you know it's
interesting because that is one of the
things that has changed there have
always been people who are kind of
screwed right maybe the big employer was
the only real employer in town so if
they don't want to work at the mill well
they've got to move somewhere else and
all their friends and family live there
so but for most people I would I would
say in our society you know decades back
you could move if you really need it to
you could move from job to job it's not
quite so easy today so there's less jobs
available I mean it's it's kind of funny
because people I you know I know that
the jobs aren't very good because I've
got three of them and and the gig
economy is another big part of this as
well where people are not even being
treated as if they are employees
there's lawsuits you know still pending
about this like with uber and and and
other things instead they're treated as
private contractors who are totally
responsible for what goes on on
and and it displaces a lot of the burden
on to them so we are you know we're
really in a and we're just charting out
alike a few features of the situation
that we're heading into and what is it
going to look like for us and you know
what does a job do for a person part of
it is it supplies them an income but it
does more than that
it like you were saying just a minute
ago it signifies them as like a worthy
person in society to others to have
value yeah and and I think also it's
something internal as well a lot of
people want to be productive they want
to have something they can do sometimes
they're not in a job that lets them do
that and they might get a little burnt
out because of that or be disengaged but
not having a job at all that really does
a number on so many people not to
mention like what's the first thing that
you ask when you meet someone a lot of
times it's what do you do and what do
you say when you don't have a what do
you do I don't know I'm a part-time
amateur philosopher or something people
started having to come up with all sorts
of answers to that in the recession from
you know it started essentially in 2007
and then continued on for a while and
that was for a lot of people the first
time they'd been out of work not for
like two weeks but for months and months
on end sometimes years on end and they
they would say things like you know I'm
between positions right now and then
when somebody says that a lot of people
look at them you know okay so you're
you're basically a bum you're unemployed
you know and so people got creative with
other things so I've got a lot of irons
in the fire
yeah but so once again that this trying
to decouple your identity and your value
from the work is probably something that
we can work on as a society now why why
is that so important yeah well meaning
is very powerful in how people the
people's mental health as well as the
things that are driving him and so
there's a movement to try to decouple
meaning from work and so the idea of
especially like the purpose of earning
money is to have enough money to live
yeah and and maybe the word the purpose
of work should be to create and so if
you're decoupling the making of money
from that making of work then now you
can have something that you're creating
and you're putting meaning into that is
not directly associated with this how do
I make sure that there's food on my
table and roof over my head yeah
and this is this is a perennial issue
this goes way way back I mean Plato in
the Republic he talks about the
difference between different arts or
sciences or disciplines you know tecna's
and a pista maids in greek ways of like
knowing how to do something like
medicine for example and he says the
doctor is not about making money insofar
as he is just about making money is not
really a doctor
the art of medicine is about healing the
body or producing whatever is supposed
to be produced to the body and so
focusing on that that productive aspect
and not just on having to figure out how
to make money or how to turn what you've
got into a century a money-making knack
that would really change the meaning for
a lot of people but that that also
sounds kind of utopian it's sort of like
or we're not it necessarily utopian sort
of elitist or privileged well it's nice
if you've got the kind of career that
lets you do that
but what about the rest of us poor
working people who can't do that you
know like that's think of where we're
going with this potential post-scarcity
economy yeah you have automation and we
have the ability that this the benefits
of this automation are actually given to
everyone then it does give everyone the
opportunity to do that and you know when
you remove the need to have money from
your work it allows you to do work in a
more authentic way and without the
problem of money you do your work out of
love
yeah and because you have a talent or
affinity for it right right now this is
a good place for us to jump into talking
about there's a number of different it
seems like the the futurists and
analysts they love to talk in force I
think because you can usually at a
square then it's a nice graphic so one
one theorist who wrote about this in
Jacobin and then wrote a book later on
is Peter frost I think I'm pronouncing
his name right and he was talking about
four different possible futures for us
and he was being a bit more imaginative
than a lot of the other fours that we're
gonna talk about where they say
everyone's gonna have to work it's just
a question of how it's gonna happen he
talks about two different variables that
give us something like ask where you've
got resource abundance versus scarcity
and a Galit arianism versus hierarchy
and he says these are you know ideal
types these are not supposed to be like
everything's gonna happen exactly this
way but the universe that you're talking
about or the the possible world a
post-scarcity future like that a Star
Trek would be that where we have both
abundance of natural resources and you
know things can be coordinated properly
and egalitarianism where we we value
people equally and we we don't simply
impose force or power on them and that's
what would be needed in order to have
something like like Star Trek right
right and this is kind of a give you
there's scarcity is one of the major
factors within like a capitalist system
and if you remove scarcity then it kind
of removes the reason why there should
be prices for things in order to try to
dole those Goods out to the the right
amount of people and if there's
basically infinite good it's then
basically everyone could have whatever
they want they could consume as much as
they want
and and this is a possible future for us
when we have all these you know robotics
and AIS in in place if we as a society
decide that everybody is valued and
everybody gets to do the kind of work
that they want to do and everybody gets
what they need then we could have that
what stands in the way of that
well who owns the automation is the I
guess the main thing you know otherwise
there's some sort of inability to get
enough resources to be the inputs for
this automation so I don't know we blow
up the moon and make most of the world
uninhabitable and how Wow yes so so
another one of the options that he talks
about where you have a Galit arianism
but you also have scarcity like maybe we
do burn through our fossil fuels or and
if we burn through the fossil fuels
there go the plastics too pretty much
right there they're made from petroleum
too so we can get that from plants not
the same kind but that plants need
fossil fuels for us to grow right so
we're we're still kinda Sol so he talks
about that as being socialism and he
says nobody needs to perform labor but
people are not free to consume as much
as they they like so we have to have
like shrinking the belt but we do it in
an equal way so every everybody you know
pitches in now what if we have hierarchy
then then we have to we have either
abundance or scarcity and so a hierarchy
and abundance would be rent ISM this is
you know where there's a very few people
who own all the automation capital and
now if they need no labor then there's
no there's a decoupling between the
fortunes of the capitalists and the
origin of those people that are part of
the labor force and because you know
need the labor anymore and you just
basically turn this into rent tourism
yeah and there's like a prestige system
you could say right they they want to
hold on to some sort of distinctives
that make them better than
and everybody else and so the last one
here is hierarchy and scarce ISM which
is like the worst of all worlds here
yeah he calls it extermination and he
called he characterized it as a
communism for the few and the idea is if
if we really do have a world where we're
using up all the resources well you know
that works out good for the rich or the
powerful or the well-connected because
they can find ways to either sort of you
know do you know what mitigate any of
the the negatives of the scarcity yeah
for themselves right and then everybody
else can you know as they say pounce and
you know I was thinking about the what
is it bread and circuses right keep the
mass entertained and out of your way or
you put them somewhere else or you just
get rid of them and you see this kind of
interestingly with a lot of tech
millionaires and billionaires of doing
prepper ISM and buying bunkers in the
middle of nowhere
kind of expecting this social crash at
some point in time and they feel like
well they're gonna come for our heads so
we better have someplace to hold up
enough arms and maybe some private
security away from everyone else yeah
it's interesting when you think about
the private security what's their
incentive to stay loyal right especially
if like for example if the dollar goes
into the toilet
like right I better house like a whole
bunch of spam yeah I felt like once the
spam is the only thing and he's the guy
with the gun what was keeping him from
saying well no just give me the spam
yeah and so this is this is kind of a
really really big picture dividing up of
what our possible futures would be but
you know I think part of his point was
we have to we have to be attuned to the
fact that things could go one way or the
other and it depends on what we as a
society opt for or push before
and it's interesting because this is
like recent politics with Andrew yang
has been talking a lot about this idea
and he kind of stakes out a position
between this egalitarianism and
abundance and a hierarchy and abundance
because it's like okay there's
automation it's happening and and so his
idea to put forward was on a freedom
dividend basically instead of actually
you know making all the automation
directly under the control of the
government and this would be like you're
strapped capitalism yeah on that you
still have our scenario communism you
still have like capitalist system but
you just tax the heck out of the
automation and say we've built the
system together and we should then reap
the benefits of the system together yeah
you know it's it's interesting if you
think about the logic of that and you
were to like put it right in the present
who would you be taxing the the huge
tech companies right because they
already have massive it's not a lot of
robots necessarily doing everything
although they're trying to move as far
as quickly as possible to that but if
you think about the amount of data that
Amazon Facebook Google Apple and
Microsoft collect on us through either
directly themselves or all their
subsidiaries and all of the you know the
money that they're they're bringing in
very little of which is actually taxed
and thereby used for for socially
beneficial purposes that's where the
freedom dividend could come from you
know right but I don't see yang saying
that or am I wrong ah I'm not sure I
think he's more worried about
manufacturing yeah then automation you
know this is a little bit off topic but
who do we think is actually gonna do the
manufacturing you know and all the
robots is it likely that it's gonna be
new companies rising up or is it likely
it's going to be these massive tech
conglomerates who are the the biggest
you know
capitalize they have the largest market
caps in in in all of history and in the
current economy they effectively
dominate the economy what do you think I
mean I think it's gonna be a mix of some
old companies and and some new ones that
find a niche okay that will explode into
this you know there's well what they
call the massive pool of money and this
is kind of back from the big short which
is about the 2008 financial crisis one
of the reasons why there was so much
demand for these tranche housing
mortgages was that there's like several
trillion dollars of money just in bank
accounts especially in at least in that
time in China that were looking for
someplace to get returned and so there's
a lot of potential liquid capital out
there for if someone has a really good
idea that could you know have that 10x
return it could definitely happen okay
yeah so can that make sense
accommodation of both let's talk about
because I don't think we're gonna have
time to talk about all three of the
things that we were looking at let's
talk about something that the Brits came
up with from the Royal Society's action
and Research Center report they talked
about four futures of work now here it's
less big picture and a little bit more
zooming in they talked about four
different scenarios or economies that
would still involve a lot of people
being at work this is looking forward to
2035 which you know that's in our
lifetime I think that's kind of a
realistic window might happen before
that right things diverge the farther we
go out so they talked about what they
call the big tech economy the precision
economy the exodus economy and the
empathy economy and let's talk about the
last one first because it sounds it
sounds like it's a little bit along the
way
the post-scarcity Star Trek 1 right yeah
I guess what would you consider the
major tenets of that one they so they
talked about in the report that it
involves a future of responsible
stewardship so technology doesn't just
run away right and it's not a purely
market driven so it's not driven by the
two forces of holycrap can we do this
really cool thing or wow we can make a
ton of money with this there's some
humane values involved right and and and
they they they're cognizant of what the
technology could do that would be bad
and tech companies self-regulate to keep
themselves keep some moral compass now
this might be a little utopia look a
little skeptical right I'm very
skeptical of deal at least all the tech
companies you know some of them might
try to self regularly Google used to
have the motto don't be evil
I'm totally vacuous yeah well I think
they actually meant it in the beginning
but you know so much in time you you
either what is it I you die quick enough
to be the hero or you live long enough
to be the villain yeah yeah and and not
even like even if you had a couple tech
companies that were moral there's always
those people that are out there that are
like well they're not gonna do it I
don't have the moral scruples to not do
it and so I'll go out and do this thing
yeah so I don't think you can accomplish
this without some sort of oversight and
regulation you know but if that happened
so you know there would be all this
innovation and development and and we
would be in in a different world in 2035
but like they say you know you'd have a
lot of funds flowing into what they call
these empathy sectors which I think are
very important education right every 20
years we got to relearn everything for a
new generation care for others and and
then also entertainment so that would be
one outcome and okay it's
it's kind of interesting like looking at
like Japan which has a very large
elderly population and they're throwing
so much money into that sector of their
economy also adding an automation to
that to try to make robots that are
doing like homecare and whatnot and it
kind of comes down to what is your
optimization function are you optimizing
just for profits or are there other
things that we as a society and as an
economy need to optimize for and you
know for a long time I believe that like
profits were a couple very strongly with
overall well-being but if you get to the
extremes here I think that reverses and
the the D couple harshly especially if
only a few people have all of the
capital and they don't any of the labor
and when you're saying they decouple you
mean that there's almost an inverse
relation with one where the more profits
are making the less well being there is
right right okay yeah I guess overall
well-being
I'd say that's right and one of the
things maybe we need to think about is
well how do you when these thing has
been separated apart from each other for
decades how do you get them back
together again because that's that's a
challenge for us as we're moving into
this this new world let's talk about
some of the other economies so they they
also talk about the big tech economy
which is where the the you know
technologies develop at a rapid pace
there's significant improvements in
quality of products public services and
unemployment and economic insecurity
start creeping upward and and workers
and unions are basically just stock they
there's not much that they can do about
it that seems to be where we are going
as the default if we're not careful yeah
like look at the the gig economy and a
whole bunch of workers that are really
you know full-time workers but they're
independent contractors and thus they
have no leverage over the employers
slash you know contract holders that
they actually work for
yeah so another one that they talked
about that's also rather dystopic is the
exodus economy where you would have some
sort of economic slowdown and this this
could be the case I mean they're talking
about for for Britain that could happen
here that can happen in China that can
happen in any of the big drivers and you
can get a vicious cycle where there's
there's you know less money in the
economy less innovation and which
prompts the government to then impose
austerity which then stifles the economy
and the you know it goes and goes yeah I
guess like Greece and Italy right yeah
yeah how does that affect the ordinary
person as opposed to the captain of
industry right well there's less
opportunities for them and they they may
find themselves without work just
because they're there's not enough work
to to go around so and it's interesting
that like the expects if this were to
happen then cooperatives and Mutual's
would emerge in large number to serve
the people's core economic needs
yeah good energy and banking do you
optimistic I I find it interesting of
these four that's the only one where it
came up and that it seems like some of
these different ways of structuring our
economy and who shares in the benefits
of our economy good that cooperatives
and Mutual's could be potential like
release valves for moving away from one
of their worst positions maybe that's
why they put in is like you know if it
says like the the people are become
disillusioned with capitalism yeah and
so they they move to really
fundamentally different forms on the
economy you know it's interesting and I
don't want to spend too much time in
this but when I talk with my students
you know Gen Z students they will say
things to me quite routinely like what
do I care about the capitalist economy
you know what's it doing for me and you
can you know you can do the
advocate Wow look at all the innovation
they're like man I'm so cut off from all
that sort of stuff it's not helping me
really at all and this this lack of
buy-in is gonna be a real problem I
think you know you know let's talk very
quickly about the the precision economy
this is what their their way of talking
about what they call a future of hyper
surveillance so this is when you're
being monitored all the time like you
know for instance when you work from
home you know looking through the webcam
somebody's watching to see whether your
eyes are actually on the document that
you're supposed to be doing or whether
you're watching a YouTube video right so
what kind of I mean that may be the
future of work for many of us I hope not
as well especially because it's like
this idea that we should be at our desks
for eight hours is a relic of a factory
job where if you weren't at the factory
on the wine weren't get anything
productive done but especially when
we're doing a lot of uh you know
thinking based work on that they are say
that you only work like an office job
like 40 percent of the time if you're
actually being productive you know go
back to that Peter Principle yeah so
you're also onto something that we also
probably do need like these herbs and
flows right you can't all be peak
performance all the time or we're gonna
burn out very quickly and so a number of
companies have moved to just an output
base they don't care how much you
actually sit down and work they're like
okay well you need you know here's our
our outline of like you know save your
programming it's like I need to have a
function that does this and it's like
okay I did that and like okay grid and
you're still you're in good sorts here's
your salary and so it's not like you
have to be sitting there and and looking
at code for eight hours yeah you know I
totally agree you know absent flows if
I'm looking at code for eight hours I'm
going to burn out yeah and you might
actually only get those top levels of
the waves if we're using this AB and
flow metaphor by having those troughs
all right so if you don't have that then
it has to like be lowered down but part
of the problem with the economy that
we're in because there's this emphasis
on like gotta always have more and more
productivity I think we've actually hit
with the human element of things in many
cases we've already hit like peak
productivity you know you can you can
make things a little bit more effective
here and there and you know do all sorts
of flowcharts and use you know task
management software but I don't think
you're gonna get that much more out of
people than you currently are in many
cases as diminishing returns yeah so
this this surveillance economy would be
trying to I guess squeeze everything
possible out of the workers which is
gonna suck for the the people who are
living within it all right yeah so kind
of idea of like being always on always
putting on this fake base to make sure
especially if your customer facing you
know in your being instantly rated you
know yeah Blackmore did yeah but
actually before Black Mirror on
community did it with the meow-meow B's
tell me about that cuz I didn't watch
community I watched like a first couple
seasons I think and then I something
happened I just to not there was an
episode of which Tim and Eric from the
Tim and Eric show if you're familiar
yeah were co-starring and they might
have actually helped write it but it was
basically that episode of black mirror
where basically era what they got an app
and everyone was constantly raiding each
other and it turned into kind of this
like post-apocalyptic you know five
stars versus three to one you know and
four obviously uh-huh I forgot to like
zero yeah on but like it like turned
into this caste system where the five
stars were all like getting constantly
pampered because their five star nests
gave more power to give anyone else
because you know their ratings were
weighted higher interesting
yeah so that that is definitely a danger
there let's talk I think you know before
we talk about a challenge or practice
that people could put into play let's
talk about why all this is is important
so you know we've been doing a lot of
time a lot of discussion of very big
picture stuff how does this impact the
ordinary person who might be listening
to the show and wants to hear how
philosophy is helping to improve their
life well I mean one oh go ahead
oh there's two major components there's
the material necessity of the individual
are their families you know getting that
food on the table getting you know warm
clothes to put on your and your
children's backs and then there's the
you know the meaning component and if a
lot of this are going to be trying to
figure out how are we going to be going
forward in our world and meeting those
two needs yeah and so for the first need
the the economic the putting food on the
table and roof over the head and all
these proverbial things car wheels on
your car whatever it's gonna be I guess
you can say that you know that you can
look at in a very individualistic way I
need to do what what's going to be
helpful for me or perhaps for my family
but you can also look at it a more group
oriented way where you're like well what
could we do together to make things more
humane to set up buffers where we're not
all sort of exposed to the elements of
the marketplace and just a couple steps
away from not having what we what we
need you know and this might require
more organization and I don't know right
now that our current labor unions are
the device to do that but I don't have
any I don't have anything else to say
other than that there's other
alternatives out there that people can
explore yeah like labor unions are to a
certain extent kind of dinosaurs they're
a relic of a previous age in which
you know labor was much more strongly
tied to your employment you know you
would work at the same job in 40 years
and you'd retire what do you think about
the idea of some of the other like
attempts to unionize things like uber or
some of these you know some of these
other tech companies do you see
prospects there for creating a buffer
where people are gonna be less subject
to the vicissitudes of the marketplace
or I don't know if they're they're ever
going to work it's it's like I wish that
there was a better balance between you
know the political power of Labor and
capital and I think they could
definitely improve the overall working
conditions of the worker yeah but I'm
not sure if the way that our system is
currently set up that actually allows
for that to happen yeah so I mean then
some people they will screw the system
you know I don't know that that's that
viable of a response coming back to the
other side of it though the meaning side
I think a lot of people are very
vulnerable because we still do in fact
high our meaning of ourselves as workers
to the work that we do and to the
availability of work so this is
something that happened you know in a
major way in the 2008 recession many
people who had never really been out of
work for a long time
found themselves unable to find anything
for months and months on end and
sometimes for years and it did
incredible psychological damage to those
people now why was that the case because
they identified themselves so closely
with their earning potential or having a
title or having a place to go where you
have an office so what what you know
what would you say people ought to do
well you shouldn't either develop a
non-work goal for your life and derive
meaning from that or you know as I spoke
about I think last week the the paper I
wrote which I believe is called
the locust of meaning but tried to make
this argument that you should have an
abstraction that like a category in
which you could fit your meaning and one
way that it would manifest would be your
work but he could also have that
manifest in many other ways that are
non-work-related
that was that was in stoicism today
right right so we'll put a link to that
for people who are listening so you can
you can track that down and and you
don't have to try to google it and yeah
you know I like that that approach to it
which is you know some of your meeting
could be in your work you just don't
want to have all of the eggs in that one
single basket like Willy Loman because
then it's going to be a Death of a
Salesman you could have you know one egg
in this basket and one egg in this
basket one and they get what they call
diversification right and in investing
that seems to be a rather prudent thing
to do now that touches on the practice
that we were going to talk about so say
a little bit more about picking a non
non work goal for your life what does
that mean
so this came to the idea of like
decoupling your work from your meaning
and so you can think of like finding a
hobby maybe something that is that you
can constantly be learning about and
this idea of like maybe try to promote a
lifelong learning you know be someone
that would be an autodidact and so for
example like I found that in philosophy
I find it very enjoyable it is
definitely not my job but I do derive a
lot of meaning from it I you know I look
forward to having this conversation with
Gregg weekly much more than I do going
to work that's that's a nice
recommendation and even for somebody
like myself who's you know paid to do
philosophy I don't actually have to
study most of the stuff that I study you
know I could just like just focus in on
the things that I'm actually getting
paid to but I you know I like reading
some other things on the side and
thinking about them
and I think there really is something to
this this idea of finding something
where it's not just about the the output
that that's it becomes like a rock that
you can rely upon when as is probably
going to happen to all of us we're out
of work well and also the end like when
we retire what do you do once you retire
yeah that may be a whole other
conversation that we know right to have
down the line so we don't actually have
any any quote or quip to go out of the
only any word of wisdom you want to
impart before we go vidi vidi vici here
here comes a I - I came songkong also
it's the a I saying that right yeah now
when when the a I can actually say that
and mean it it truly will be here right
right well
[Music]
you